Activists say Syria's military forces fire heavy machine guns...
...and launch artillery attacks against anti - government protesters.
In Yemen, a cease-fire between government forces...
...and opposition tribesmen in the country breaks down.
In Libya, South African President and peace mediator Jacob Zuma...
...says he is unable to broker a deal with leader Moammar Gadhafi.
Fishing boats lie stranded on the parched banks of China's Lake Honghu...
...as drought threatens the livelihoods of millions.
In Peru, thousands of Aymara protesters march in the city of Puno...
...against plans by a Canadian company to open a silver mine.
In Spain, Colombian pop star Shakira grooves with Barcelona Champions League winners.